Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan.
Es ist warm.
Ja, wir sind in der Katarobik. Gleich geht es nach dem Live-Salon. Wir wollen aber erst einmal ankündigen, dass wir als nächstes lesen werden. Und zwar dachten wir, nachdem du dich so intensiv mit den Männer Podcasts beschäftigt hast, sollten wir auch den Autor eines Podcasts an den Mittelpunkt drücken, nämlich Robin Alexander. Der hat ein Buch geschrieben, das für uns, glaube ich, besonders relevant ist, weil wir so viel über die AfD gesprochen haben, aus einer Perspektive, die jetzt die ganze Zeit sich fragt, was muss von links getan werden, um die AfD zu verhindern? Jetzt schreibt Robin Alexander ein Buch, das heißt Letzte Chance, was jetzt die CDU gerade machen muss, um die Demokratie zu retten, um die AfD zu verhindern. Also für Robin Alexander ist klar, dass also nur über eine gewisse CDU, wie sie dann aussieht, wird er uns vorstellen, es möglich ist, die AfD zu stoppen. Ich glaube, diesen Perspektiv wechseln einzunehmen scheint sinnvoll.
Ja, genau, Perspektivwechsel. Ich halte das nämlich für dann wahrscheinlich eine sehr streitbare Lektüre.
Ich denke auch.
Wenn wir hören, dass nur noch die CDU uns vor der AfD beschützen kann.
Genau.
Da hat man schon ganz viele Ideen von, wir brauchen konstruktive Angebote, entweder pragmatisch oder ideologisch abgeräumt.
Ja, ja.
Also begeben wir uns mal diese Tiefen.
Es ist noch einmal auch so eine Analyse, glaube ich, für uns vielleicht das letzte Mal, so eine Analyse des Konservatismus im Sinne von, wir dürfen konservativ sein, aber es darf keine Partei rechts der CDU geben. Also ich glaube, das ist noch einmal so einmal der Versuch, dieses Konzept noch mal stark zu machen.
Aber wenn das nur so heißt, die letzte Chance, dann ist das ja für uns auch die letzte Chance.
Ich denke.
Ob da noch mal was zu holen ist aus der CDU.
Ja, und das führt uns eigentlich schon zu unserem Live-Summer heute. Es ist ein bisschen anders. Wir sind etwas politiklastiger heute. Aber es ist so viel in der Welt, dass wir dachten, wir müssen jetzt auch mal jenseits des Klamauks über sehr relevante Dinge sprechen, und zwar über die AfD. Und zwar hat Maximilian Krah in Schnellroda die Kubitscheks besucht und mit denen über die Strategie der AfD diskutiert. Und die Kubitscheks werfen Krah vor, dass er ja jetzt so ein Liberaler wird oder nicht mehr so richtig an der Migration glaubt. Und was ist denn da eigentlich los? Man hat viele Fragen an Krah. Und wir werden jetzt sehr schön sehen können, wie Maximilian Krah Staatsvolk und ethnisches Volk, wie er das versteht, wie er Staatsbürgerschaft versteht. Und eine These jetzt von mir, also es sind viele Dinge, die wir ansprechen werden, eine These von mir ist, woran jetzt Maximilian Krah arbeitet, ist tatsächlich die Normalisierung der AfD. Und zwar nicht im Sinne von unsere Normalisierung, wie da an den Talkshows eigentlich nur so, sondern die AfD normalisiert sich auch selbst. Man könnte sagen, sie zählt sich ein bisschen. Aber in gewisser Weise wird sie jetzt noch gefährlicher im Sinne von wird sie gewählt werden. Und das ist also eine hochinteressante Debatte.
Genau, denn wenn Robin Alexander's letzte Chance vertan ist, ist das die erste Chance für Jens Schwan. Ja, das ist das große Projekt. Wir gucken heute außerdem auch Hoss & Hopf. Sie haben eine große Live-Show gemacht, vier Stunden lang. Da steckt nichts drin. Wir hören nur einen kleinen Ausschnitt. Jemand war ja maulwurfartig vor Ort und hat uns Audio-Material dargelassen. Aber wie gesagt, das schauen wir nur beispielhaft, um zu sagen, da steckt nichts drin, aber im Podcast. Wir machen heute, wir haben euch den Grundbegriff schon gefunden, Synchrotismus. Was ist, wenn man eine große Linie einfach umdeutet, eine große historische Linie einfach umdeutet? Das wird in diesem Podcast gemacht. Und ich glaube, wenn man das historische Programm der Semantik gegenüberstellt, ist es auch ein bisschen amüsant. Für Live-Publikum genau richtig, glaube ich. Dann Polen. Wir haben eine Präsidentenwahl in Polen gehabt, die mit 0,8 Prozent oder so entschieden wurde. Und meine These ist, es war Dobrindt. Merz und Dobrindt, die sind schuld. Und das lässt sich aus deutschem Nachrichtenmaterial auch, finde ich, sehr eindeutig heraushören. Es ist nur die Frage, wie offen ist man für das Argument, zu sagen, im Grunde brauchen wir keine LA-Gerichterstattung, um uns darüber zu ereifern, was hier gerade passiert. Sondern wir sehen das auch in Deutschland mit den Zurückweisungen. Nur haben wir unseren politischen Gorilla noch contained. Wir haben keine Demokraten in Kalifornien, die einfach einen Niedriglohnsektor so bereitet haben, dass sie allen so eher in Dürft zum Bleiben aus dem Gutwill. Und dann plötzlich regieren die anderen und die haben keinen Gutwill. Und alle sind vogelfrei. In Deutschland haben wir noch ein Grundgesetz und Gerichte, die funktionieren. Und plötzlich hat man Politik in gleicher Intensität, aber noch hinter Gittern. Mal gucken, wie lange.
Wir beenden den Abend dann mit Matthias Döpfner. Der hat nämlich ein Personality-Interview gegeben. Und wir sehen ja in ihm den Milliardär, den Konzernchef, den Medienmacher.
Das Vorbild der Zeitungspräsident.
Ja, aber er möchte als Mensch gesehen werden. Und das werden wir heute mal tun. Natürlich nicht nur, um uns nochmal mit Döpfner zu beschäftigen und ein bisschen lustig zu machen, sondern wirklich auch, um nochmal genau diese Ideologie bloßzulegen, dass dann Leute jetzt immer mehr kommen in die Podcast hinein, migrieren und sagen Hallo, ich würde jetzt gerne mal nur über mich sprechen und meine Kindheit und meine Mutter und so weiter.
Wenn einer Menschen sieht in dieser Welt, dann da wohl Marcel H.
Schmitt. Ja, also auch das muss heute besprochen werden. Und all das kann man ganz einfach hören, nämlich wenn man uns abonniert. Das ist möglich, wenn man Apple-Kunde ist und will da auch die Apple-Welt nicht verlassen. Dann kann man das einfach im Shop anklicken und kommt dann zu diesem Live-Sanon und auch zu allen anderen Salons. Sonst kann man die 2-Stunden-Show natürlich auch sehen, wenn man uns über Patreon oder Steady abonniert. Wir referieren Steady. Da kommt man ganz einfach hin. Man geht auf unsere Seite neuzwanziger.de. Da ist ein goldener Button. Da klickt man drauf. Und dann kann man ein Abo abschließen und hat dann Zugang zu allen regulären Salons und natürlich auch zu den Live-Salons.
So ist es.
Dann gehen wir hinaus.
Dann gehen wir mal hinaus. Es ist nicht mehr so heiß wie sonst. Ich wollte einen Scherz machen in die Hölle, aber nein. Wir haben es sehr klimatisiert. Wir haben es sehr klimatisiert. Bis gleich. Macht ihr uns ein bisschen weniger Licht, damit wir am Anfang zumindest noch mehr sehen. Es scheint wahnsinnig gesundes Publikum zu sein, denn so wenig Hinweise auf, ich muss mein Ticket noch loswerden und so gab es nie. Also ihr seid alle topfit und die Hitze macht euch auch nichts. Das ist sehr gut. Und uns auch nicht.
Es wird nicht ganz so lange wie der Parsifal. Gestern waren ja schon einige mit im Parsifal in der Oper. Es hat fünf Stunden gedauert, also eine ganz typische Neue-Zwanziger-Folge. Jetzt natürlich nur zwei Stunden.
Wer war denn mit dabei?
Ja, hier sind so ein paar. Und hat es dir gefallen?
Ja, klar.
Ja, ich hatte ja mit der Inszenierung meine Schwierigkeiten, will es sie aber nicht ausführen. Aber es war musikalisch beeindruckend.
Ihr seht mich schlotternd. Wolfgang hat mir eben kurz gesagt, er hat eine Frage zu Parsifal.
Ich frage dich jetzt, der vielleicht berühmteste Satz neben Zum Raum wird hier die Zeit ist ja, die Wunde schließt der Sperr nur, der sie schlug. Und ist das eigentlich unser Motto in diesem Podcast? Denn wir bringen immer schreckliche Leute mit, um uns dann von denen zu lösen oder zu reinigen.
Also gestern war ein sehr großer Fallos auf der Bühne in Form eines Sperrs, damit es nicht so anstößig ist. Der wurde natürlich hin und her geschwungen und so weiter. Und dieses Bild des Sperrs habe ich auch häufiger in meinen Texten verwendet, wenn ich nämlich sage, und da saß der Interviewgast, der den Sperr zurückwarf, wie er zu ihm geflogen kam. Und so ein bisschen machen wir das heute auch. Also wir haben heute Krah, Hoss und Hopf und Dopfner, Kubitschek. Also heute volle Packung. Und wenn du Party-Wal zitierst, ich war am Dienstag ja auch in der Oper, in Melusine, du hast sie verpasst. Der tollste Satz, der da auch auf Deutsch gesungen wurde, war, ich versuche mein Schicksal zu entziffern. Dafür sind wir heute hier, wir entziffern heute unser Schicksal.
Wunderbar, dann klingen wir los.